histrionics and hyperbole on Capitol
Hill as the DHS secretary Kirsten
Nielsen was interrogated by Senators on
the Judiciary Committee
if c-span handed out Best Supporting
Actor Awards a gold statuette would
surely go to New Jersey senator Cory
Booker why am i frankly seething with
anger the commander-in-chief in an oval
office meeting referring to people from
African countries and Haitians with the
most vile and vulgar language both
language Fester's your silence and your
amnesia is complicity the fact pattern
is clear of the threats in this country
I hurt where dick durbin called me I had
tears of rage when I heard about this
experience in that meeting and for you
not to feel that hain't hurt and that
pain and to dismiss some of the
questions of my colleagues that's
unacceptable to me tears of rage that's
actually bad acting give me a break now
did senator Booker cry tears of rage
when this story broke in his home state
of New Jersey just a few months ago
we're an illegal alien named Edgar
Mendoza broke into a Trenton home and
raped a six-year-old little girl now we
looked and we couldn't find a single
comment by senator Booker about this
heinous crime of unspeakable cruelty
does he not feel the hurt of the child's
mother and father a crime that should
have never happened because that man
should have never been in this country
senator his silence and it's
unacceptable and complicit at least to
me Booker is simply out testing campaign
themes it's patently obvious Oprah had
her moment at the Golden Globes and he's
not about to cede that spotlight that
quickly no way here he was back in 2010
joking around with private citizen Trump
seems pretty happy to be sitting with a
racist doesn't he Booker stunned today
was an attempt to reinforce the Trump
is a racist narrative we've been seeing
it all week and for back up five liberal
congressmen and women are staging their
own stunts they're boycotting trumps
state of the Union speech now what does
that accomplish other than maybe give
them another free night to binge watch
on Netflix and speaking of wasting time
the left-wing American press willingly
lined up to do what they do best
play the hallelujah chorus to the
Democrats storyline for them slandering
the president beats reporting on his
great economy any time facts be damned
president white supremacist that is
absolutely racism with steroids the
President of the United States is racist
we have a racist a shameless racist who
has hijacked the Republican Party who
has hijacked the Oval Office I would say
judging by his words and his deeds
racist a hard rain is going to fall on
Donald Trump and the Republicans who
enable this sort of racism so tie
herself but a positively bizarre scene
unfolded at the White House briefing
today by the president's physician
members of the media actually think that
a military doctor is part of the White
House scheme to conceal the president's
true mental condition from all of us
there isn't anything that's a part of
the president's health records or his
overall
physical fitness or any medications that
he's taking that you're not permitted to
tell us is there anything you're keeping
from us for privacy reasons if anyone
ever needed extensive cognitive
screening my goodness what medications
are you on Acosta now there were endless
questions about Trump's diet his workout
routine or lack thereof what do you like
to see that routine his weight and one
reporter asked the doctor for his waist
measurements you first sweetheart
then this afternoon a member of NBC's
investigative unit tweeted out this gem
seeing a lot of skepticism over the idea
that real Donald Trump weighs only 239
pounds when he stepped on a scale and
public to prove it yeah he'll do that
when reporters and anchors agree to
public lie detector tests during their
broadcast or after their broadcast as
Trump's team is renegotiating NAFTA
freeing up our energy sector smashing
Isis cracking down on ms-13 all the rest
the Democrats and a gaggle of globalist
never Trump furs and of course everybody
in the media are making complete and
total buffoons of themselves it's
actually embarrassing no self-respect
because of their phony politicized
bluster on race what's gonna happen I'll
tell you what's gonna happen more
Americans will end up tuning them out
and sadly in the process tuning out real
racism when it happens and if Democrats
really decide to put amnesty for illegal
immigrants ahead of funding the
government for American citizens
they'll have blown yet another
opportunity to be a party of solutions
instead of stunts Ronald Reagan once
said that governments have a tendency
not to solve problems only to rearrange
them well eager to change that sad
reality the Trump administration is
actually working to expand economic
opportunity for all Americans and also
solve complicated problems along the way
I ask you this what other president has
stood up to China and it's theft of
American intellectual property
and it's a myriad of unscrupulous trade
practices name one and what other
president has begun to bring capital and
manufacturing back to the United States
they all said it was impossible right
Trump didn't believe them and what other
president has insisted on immigration
changes that will benefit working-class
Americans instead of just benefiting the
wealthy all of those rich people who
want their cheap labor he is doing this
an enduring constant non-stop unfair
nasty criticism and he's doing it for
one simple reason to improve the
standard of living for the American
people people of all races and at every
economic level and while it is true that
President Trump can sometimes step on
his own good news sometimes of course
saying nothing is the best thing and
maybe you should abide by that once in a
while he's actually trying to do what so
many politicians have promised but could
not deliver a better stronger and yes a
more united America my friends I will
take solutions over stunts any day of
the week and that's the angle